pour moi la question ils étaient 1
tendancieuses vicieuse et blessantes
alors spontanément j'ai fait ce geste
que je regrette alors je m'excuse auprès
d'eux j'ai des petites vers chaque c'est
non non ça a été une période difficile
pour moi tout simplement acheté une
paire ce fut blessé alors j'ai fait sur
ça sans aucune mauvaise volonté sans
aucune mauvaise volonté le bâlois était
il ya déjà beaucoup de collègues qui
sont qui sont avec moi alors des fois
les caméras parce qu'ils sont cons mais
il faudrait près tous y aller voir ce
qu'ils sont solidaires et aujourd'hui je
me suis aperçu que j'avais beaucoup de
gens qui étaient solidaires les bleus
bruce ben écoutez moi je vous dis que
j'ai reçu un accueil extraordinaire
aujourd'hui d'apporter mon caucus et la
commission en tout respect pour la
commission elle va terminer son rapport
et enr des recommandations pour vos
laissé faire le travail à la commission
l'a écouté parce qu'elle laissait croire
que moi je vais pas donner ma version à
moi alors dans la vie on a le droit de
postes souvenir de quelque chose je
pense pas que ce soit illégale et on
parle de financement légal ici y avait
rien qui n'était pas correcte non plus
d'en lancer dans cette chose-là à l'âge
c'est pour moi c'était une
responsabilité délégués et je n'avais
pas le souvenir comme en un peu comme en
ai parlé tout simplement
alors j'ai dit la vérité au plus
porteurs
écoutez je voulais dit tout à l'heure
j'avais des collègues et qui est qui qui
avaient une opinion plein à baidoa keven
opinion puis ont malheureusement
l'immédiat ont montré ce qui était
plutôt divergents mais moi aujourd'hui
je vois que j'ai une grande partie du
caucus qui est solidaire qui est avec
moi et je suis très heureuse d'être de
retour très très amusant
si oui tout à fait toutes les questions
tout à fait bah écoutez moi je connais
monsieur bergeron il était mon critiques
pendant j'étais aux transports je
connais le personnage connaît sa
personnalité alors ça ne m'a pas étonné
tout simplement merci beaucoup au revoir